depuis 2015 le maire de dorval reçois
des messages d'internautes partout au
monde
ce message-là lui remercie d'avoir tenu
tête aux parents d'élèves musulmans qui
lui demandait de bannir le port des
cantines scolaires
je sens un problème avec cette histoire
là c'est jamais arrivé ça a été inventé
de toutes pièces
je m'appelle janvier voici l'histoire de
québec
[Musique]
vous avez peut-être vu cette publication
qui circule sur facebook depuis quatre
ont salué cette bonne initiative dans
québécois tout ça a été démenti quand ça
commence à circuler en 2010
j'ai trouvé deux versions de ce même
texte une partager 124 mille fois et
l'autre cent soixante dix huit mille
fois sur facebook
ces deux publications là ont été créés
après que les journalistes étaient ma
part je trouve donne une idée de
l'ampleur de la chose l'article partagée
de tous les médias quebecor cours des 12
derniers mois
c'est ce texte de la presse lewis 62
mille poissons facebook donc on voit que
l'histoire maire de dorval c'est un
monstre
je dis toujours et toujours cet espoir
du barça s'est vraiment passé
mais c'est arrivé en france en janvier
2013 les parents d'élèves de la ville
d'antibes dans le sud du pays recevait
une lettre de la mairie ont expliqué que
le port ce que j'appelle des cantines
scolaires
la lettre disait que certains parents
l'avaient demandé pour des raisons
religieuses personnelles
c'est là que la nouvelle s'est mise à
circuler sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup de gens ce n'est qu'on parlait
de parents musulmans un bloc
nationaliste français écrit une lettre
ouverte au maire d'antibes jean leonetti
pour le féliciter
si possible que cette lettre ils vous
disent quelque chose et c'est normal la
pause nouvelles qui circulent à propos
du maire de dorval c'est identique c'est
le même texte
on a tout simplement changé le nom de la
ville d'antibes pour le nom de la ville
de dorval et si tout ce que ça a pris
pour créer la force nouvelle la plus
populaire du québec
cette hausse vers l'est sur le port
juste au québec elle circule un peu
partout au monde on trouve plusieurs
versions par plusieurs pays dans
plusieurs langues
d'ailleurs juste dans les dernières
semaines l'histoire a été reprise par un
site israélien est un site de fausses
nouvelles américaines
pas surprenant donc que le maire de
dorval reçoivent régulièrement des
messages pour le féliciter selon son
attachée de presse message là
proviennent surtout de mire king de gens
ailleurs au canada depuis la section du
site web de la ville sur 7 postes bella
a été la 12
elle n'a pu consulter en 2010 on connaît
pas l'identité de la personne qui écrit
cette course nouvelle la même chose est
certaine elle savait très bien ce
qu'elle faisait et qui achètent est un
mensonge
[Musique]